the gyro can experience one of my
favorite videos that you ever did was
that is it was a BB I that did Oh Joey's
Seeley's car yeah that cars for sale is
it really hope you want it that's a
lovely car and it is for sale it was
called project nasty I think he got it
down to maybe 2,200 pounds it was though
it's the lightest 964 I ever drove but
it was so light has no headliner yeah no
not my metal inside of it and everything
I remember watching it go and look at
that thing yeah but that's we said that
was really interesting was that this is
the kind of car you build when you you
know you make cars for other people yeah
yeah you want to build something for
yourself you build something that most
folks kind of that company's known for
like these really high-end like custom
builds of Porsches and they make crazy
fast things dude you can buy I mean you
can write a check right now you could
just write a check walk away come back
in two months and have like a 1500
horsepower night that's because these
guys you know these guys race runways
out here now that's like the thing now
is run runway racing so they go out and
they go side by side half mile and
they're doing like 220 230 and a half
mile you ever see a video I'm sure you
have of the guy in the GTR and the
Nurburgring and just catches air oh yeah
that's [ __ ] terrifying
you should go drive atterberg ring would
you a guy fly yeah but you wouldn't fly
through the air
you wouldn't fly you would drive the
Nurburgring a more normal car that
doesn't fly yeah I would drive something
and by the way after that they change
they sculpted that section of track
really yes they they for a period of
time st. they imposed a speed limit even
during races yeah through that section
to prevent that from happening again
they changed I believe the rules of the
racing series to slow the cars down and
then I believe they Reese Culp did the
track there as well after that incident
so they couldn't catch air like that or
at least to make it substantially less
likely yeah that [ __ ] cars catching
air is a you goose tonight and then
you're next
net dive google google racecar racecar
sketch no attempt to look for that but I
end up with people are going so fast and
people lose it all the time
dude it's it's such a fun scary crazy
place it's every every reputation that
every bit of reputation it's earned it
deserves and it's but you got to doing
it is like one of the more unique
experience of your life and you don't
have to like you know like you said you
don't have to go for time you can just
go and drive it as a fast fun Road which
is what I've done and as Americans we
should be ashamed that the Germans have
the Nurburgring I mean come on Hitler
built it if we want to really be really
I mean he didn't physically lay the
asphalt but it was a Hitler it was a
Fourth Reich superiority thing right
alongside the Autobahn suss racetracks
best race cars best highways as part of
their deal yeah that makes sense there
was so much engineering that came out of
that group of [ __ ] psychos yeah
really Oh which I love called blitzed
drugs in the Third Reich that was
basically just about how much meth they
were all on and it is nuts
of course yeah of course yeah dude even
on speed forever soon as he figured out
speed people were on speed oh and
they're giving it to the pilots and his
soldiers and leur had a speed probably
was doing speed balls like [ __ ] John
Belushi I mean it was it was crazy yeah
there was there was theorized that they
had given the Japanese and feta means to
get him to crash into the plane yeah
crashed their planes into the boats
rather yeah kamikazes yeah that was a
thought I totally believe it will mess
them up and be like had said to war
there's a story in this book about there
they at the very end of the war where
they invented these single-person
submarines basically just a floating
coffin and they sent these people out
with like 10 tablets of meth and nothing
else
and this little submarine that had a
little gun and like none of them came
back to I just can't not that I have
sympathy for Nazis but messed up
soldiers and death submarines maybe a
little bit
is that what it was that little thing I
don't think it worked I think of this
they tried a bunch of times it's a
[ __ ] sketchy oh my god yeah it's a it
doesn't how much sketchier than that
there's the one with the little hole
long time the German one man thing yes
that's it it the picture I saw had the
bubble somewhere in Colombia there's a
dude with a thousand pounds of coke
those right just got a grade the Coast
Guard knocked on the submarine
they had a cartel sub maybe something I
just knocked it's a no was it the Coast
Guard they've got yeah they're like open
the literally knocking on the literally
did they open up yeah they jumped on top
of a goddamn submarine and made the guys
open the pulse open the sides that's
right out of a goddamn it's crazy [ __ ]
so duds they jump on top of the roof of
this [ __ ] submarine holy [ __ ] look at
this yeah see so they're chasing them
they're screaming oh my god yo this is
the great [ __ ] ever dude dude how crazy
is this 25 foot long sub yeah so these
guys are following behind it he jumps
off this bad [ __ ] so we think I
think this sub is capable of full
submerging or this is this closest to
sub that it gets rightful probably can't
go down like a hundred feet but maybe
Ike holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this dude straight
up nozzle azure they hold this that's so
crazy I know I need your search terms
you are finding way better things than
me on the Internet well who who is you
know look who has taken subs and filling
them up with coke they're building that
me dude you're doing that they had that
whole big ship in Philadelphia that
cargo ship that was supposedly owned by
Chase but like had 200 or 400 million
dollars worth of cocaine really there
was what the deck heart the paris -
dakar rally is it's a car race like cars
like my safari or like built for that
right and it's a there's these you know
there's race cars and there's race
motorcycles and quads and stuff off-road
vehicles to do this very long off-road
race and then there's these support
trucks
right and they race the trucks too so
it's like these like commas and like man
trucks big off-road tires huge engines
and they're the trucks are in the race
and so these coke smugglers the trucks
the bet in the back of the truck is
enough parts to like rebuild the whole
car and the truck has a racing driver
and a five mechanic screw and they chase
the car if the car breaks they [ __ ]
pulled over and set up a shop and
rebuild the car right but they're in the
race too and so these coke smugglers
bought one of these DAC car race trucks
did it up like the livery and just like
a couple miles after the start just like
entered the race with his truck full
blow oh and they got stopped like I
don't know somewhere in the race I got
arrested with this race truck
what is this Jamie's el Chapo's so
that's el Johnson 13,000 tons of cocaine
13,000 pounds I'm sorry that's like
seven and a half wow that is crazy
30,000 pounds Jesus this one was in
Europe it had a hundred million pounds
worth oh my god these guys lose now yeah
reminds me that was that movie with Ray
Liotta no escape they built the sub Ray
Liotta and Kevin Dillon and that [ __ ] no
oh yeah what was that movie no I think
was no escape when they're on the prison
island and they get this thing fill the
subs
[Applause]